GOOD EVENING COME ON
JOHN ROBERTS AND N FOR
BRET BAIER, THE DEMOCRATS NEW
WEAPON IS THE SAME AS HIS OLD
WEAPONS.
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO
DEFEND HIMSELF AS OPPONENTS LAST
WEEKEND MASS SHOOTING IN HOYLE.
NOW SEVERAL OF THE DEMOCRATS
SEEKING TO REPLACE HIM IN THE
OVAL OFFICE ARE OPENLY CALLING
THE PRESIDENT A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
>> GOOD EVENING, JOHN, DO MASS
SHOOTINGS THIS WEEK A MONTH
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS ARE
PUSHING THE WHITE HOUSE TO CALL
AND SENATORS TO RETURN TO
WASHINGTON AND ADDRESS OF BILLS
THAT WOULD EXPAND IT BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
THEY HAVE MOVED FROM CRITICIZING
THE PRESIDENT TO CALLING HIM A
RACIST.
>> WHEN HE HAS DONE IS EVEN
WORSE, HE'S A WHITE TO PREMISED
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> CLEANING PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
RACIST AND WHITE SUPREMACIST.
SHE JOINS FORMER CONGRESSMAN AND
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN.
CAMPAIGNING IN IOWA, WARREN TOLD
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" "HE HAS
DONE THE WEEK AND THEN NOT LEAST
TALKED ABOUT WHITE SUPREMACISTS
AS FINE PEOPLE.
DONE EVERYTHING HE CAN TO STIR
UP RACIAL CONFLICT AND HATRED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THIS AFTERNOON, FORMER PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN.
>> I THINK EVERY THING THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE TO ENCOURAGE
US WHAT TO PERMISSIVE.
>> THEY ARE RUNNING A
PREDICTABLE TIRE TO PLAY, HE
REFERENCES CONGRESSMAN,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ AND
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
SINGLED OUT NEWLY ELECTED WOMEN
OF COLOR.
AT ONE WHICH THEY NEVER CEASE TO
USE WHEN THEY ARE DOWN OR RUN
OUT OF FACTS.
IF RACISM, THEY ARE TRULY
DISGUSTED.
LESS THAN A WEEK AFTER A MASS
SHOOTING IN EL PASO,
INVESTIGATORS ARE TREATING IT AS
A DOMESTIC TERRORISM CASE AND
ANOTHER IN DAYTON, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ARE AGAIN DISCUSSING
SOLUTIONS TO GUN VIOLENCE.
>> THE LARGER POINT, FRANKLY,
HERE IS WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
LEGISLATE TOGETHER.
THE PRESIDENT'S LEADERSHIP ON
TAKING REAL STEPS ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS WILL BE CRITICAL.
>> THE MAYORS OF EL PASO,
DAYTON, AND MORE THAN 200 CITIES
HAVE WRITTEN SENATE LEADERSHIP'S
TO CALL PEOPLE BACK TO
WASHINGTON TO CONSIDER A PAIR OF
HOUSE PASSED BILL THAT EXPANDS
BACK ON CHECKS.
IT "THE TRAGIC EVENTS AND
EL PASO, ARE JUST THE LATEST
REMINDERS THAT OUR NATION CAN NO
LONGER WAIT FOR OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE THE ACTIONS
NECESSARY TO PREVENT PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
FIREARMS AND BEING ABLE TO
PURCHASE THEM."
>> CEO HAS JUST RELEASED THE
STATEMENT, HE SAID THE NRA
OPPOSES ANY PROPOSAL THAT
INFRINGES ON THE RIGHTS OF
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE PREVENTED THE
SHOOTINGS FROM THIS PAST
WEEKEND.
JOHN.
>> John: MITCH McCONNELL